yeah welcome to this video playing some
gaya from from Germany with the name
funds inin which translate to translates
to out of your mind sometimes is really
playing like it's out of your mind but
some Danny plays good stuff you never
know what what's going to happen ok so
the the bogo and the line that at least
one of the lines that I'm considering
for for my book nothing that i have
studied yet or not at those chapters yet
we are trying to play play with quickly
with quicker in the opening at least I
have a 95 and must play age six first
this happens if i play a bit quicker
this happens okay so didn't okay I can
play 90 form and takes this is not a big
deal though it's um it's a pretty pretty
healthy structure so we should a five
blunders this so first t6
I of course have maybe I need to play
this in any case so we can you can play
if I def for this is what them can be a
problem
maybe Queen f6 try to get get some
technical ideas into this the Snyder's
hanging
uh actually I actually had planned Queen
g6 but c5 a subject I forgot about that
hmm interesting
it can play a form maybe it takes takes
rookie one's a bit hmm bit tricky
I can also just take it and maybe just
take it it's not too threatening anyway
I think in the end game I don't vary so
much about unless I'm losing material by
force or something otherwise his pawns
are weak c4b three deuces this is a bit
term a bit similar to them to the Berlin
Wall endgame
maybe 94 yeah I'm not exactly in good
shape in terms of development yeah man
they could become very concrete problems
with this mmm yeah all not to diss have
no they can take a swell at bishop age
three hmm okay yeah ugly this is ugly
now this maybe not so much
96 to deform the Sun an idea
okay let's get rid of one of those and
now a form wow it's giving me an a porn
hmm
I don't know am this looks and is this
dangerous for Wyatt what is the the big
big idea and don't get it
so look cookware may be here
hmm how to actually win this little King
probably king d6 and going to the a poem
mmm
check
yeah it's always check
yeah this a pawn should be promoting
yeah his spot as endgame it was very
good for white around here this must be
must be terrific for white I just I just
I don't think this is this problem
really but I am I I forgot I forgot
about this move simply twin f6 was a
true lemon I can I can play a normal
developing move here he's got this
forward for four against three so it
looks like it's an extra porn but
whenever you play if Roy we can default
so there are some counter chances for
for black I can for instance get the
night to e6 and once he goes afore I go
90 form so it's a it's so maybe I'm
about balanced position it's not nothing
spectacular but this is really a bit
there may be a 4 I thought about a 4 but
it looked well it looked very shaky
that's what it's better of all senses
this was just just terrific for white
but before was was was really amazing
just I can take it or whatever but you
cannot play before giving me an a polis
if it's really weird and b5 was the next
you can play 96 796 is probably the way
to go over there it's already tricky I
mean you cannot give me the apron yeah
thanks for watching